[Music]
[Applause]
thank you Aiden thank you everyone for
coming it's a pretty good showing so I'm
excited about that excited to be here my
name is Craig I work at web engineering
team RT uh my name is brenon I
engineering
team and uh we're going to talk about
how recently we switched over all of our
desktop web and mobile website traffic
to node from rail mon rails project and
this node these node projects are for
buzo isomorphic which just means sharing
Cod server and client so we'll dive into
how that's done and hopefully
fin so we'll start with uh why we
transitioned a node um how we did that
what our stack looks like now I'll dive
into um a project we extracted called
easel which is an ice andit boiler plate
that we use to bootstrap our projects at
RC and we'll wrap up with some wins and
pain points
from so start with why uh we chose
node um to get into that sort of have to
dive into a brief history
of R's Tex St so if you look at the
diagram here we started off pretty uh
typical monolithic rails project and
that was wildly productive for us at
first and working out really well but
soon we at that time we have a designer
so we hired a designer and we started to
get a more fancy front end uh lots more
client side job script so we adopted
backbone around like 03 um pretty early
on and at the same time we were building
an iOS prototype
uh and we needed to build out an API to
support that prototype so fast forward
and that background UI is growing and
our front end is becoming a pretty
monolithic single page background
application our API is also growing but
this entire mon rails project is just
taking on a ton of different
sponsibilities
and things are starting to get a little
messy so this was started to become on F
working uh some of the pain points of
working in this monolithic rail stack
were with a giant single page um
application our testing was pretty much
all integration testing using capara
which is a selenium driver for Ruby and
selenium fires up Firefox the web
browser and M flicks around and it's
really slow and very brittle so we had
test leads that took like two hours
paralyzed on eight machines and that
just kept growing hours long it was like
such a BC to work in that was one of the
biggest pain points of this stack so we
knew we had to fix this JavaScript
testing um also some of the things you
might hear from isomorphic Land there's
lack of reuse across the server and
client we had to start uh have faster
page loads we needed to optimize our
server side rendering but of course that
means we're duplicating Ruby libraries
like date formatting or Price libraries
um our templating libraries even though
we had h on the client and H on the
server it was hjs H Ruby and you
couldn't really reuse
them uh just the fact that it was a
large hybrid stack was a lot to boot up
not only seing the dayto days putting
for project you also have to installed
no to get because we used certain
pre-processors you have to make sure
that those libraries were installed to
one pre-processors and it just really
hard for new developers to uh get
started on this project and
again with a a single page application
at large single page application we our
initial page load was suffering greatly
we have large assets like megabyte
JavaScript and megabyte CSS files this
monolithic thing had to be broken up not
only because it was unproductive but it
was affecting our users because our page
FL was so
slow so knowing that we had to break
this up uh how did we start to introduce
node into a stack um this started before
gotten to where we are now we had the
chance the opportunity to build an
entirely separate project out side of
node we had new application entirely and
we knew that we wanted to test this idea
of having an external Client app that
was consuming our API and this was our
CMS an application we give our content
Partners manage their inventory on R and
so this we triy to Sol the main pain
point which was testing JavaScript and
what we did was we used we tested our
our client but this was still a single
page background application but we had
done a pretty good job solving the
problem of JavaScript testing by running
our client side tests using node um and
create using things like jsd to create
an environment where we can run our test
headless and really fast and actually
like see we do unit testing our
JavaScript modules so that was great and
a uh solve that testing issue for us but
eventually we KN we knew that we
couldn't maintain this giant rail
app for our main front ends as well so
we started to uh find a low hanging FR
to start introduce node into our main
front end stats and this
was again having a giant single page
application trying to responsibly handle
that was not working out in most cases
um I'm sure other people have probably
has expence on this as well but yeah so
uh again megabyte assets job CSS not
going to work on mobile uh also simply
just having very intense UI that's
catered towards a desktop screen and
then trying to turn that into something
that's significantly different and fast
enough for mobile clients this was
almost out of the question with their
current stack so we introduced we
started to think of how we can solve the
rest of our problems um using node
and so some of these again were lack of
reuse uh with the server and client so
we started to think about is it possible
to share rendering server client and
having a large monolithic assets is
there ways we can break up a giant
website into smaller pieces that we have
smaller asset packages packages cater
towards this frontend
experience um and so this was a project
that I was mostly myself but other
deaths contributed contributed to and we
pretty much rewrote all of our uh mobile
UI in four months so that was a success
for productivity
better test coverage faster page loads
Etc so after that we finally took the
learnings from that project and applied
it to our desktop website and again in
four months with four Debs this time we
were able to completely migrate all of
our uh Ro our rails front end onto this
node
path um so now Brand's going to talk a
little bit about how we were actually
able to transition this without killing
the business feature freezing and
whatnot yeah um hey so it's important to
remember that like yeah rewrites do Co
companies like we're a startup and we're
still trying to figure out our sort of
product Market fit and like halting
feature development for some like
engineering wins quote unquote like
being more productive um can kill your
company and that like other businesses
can like sort of jump you on features
and sort of beat you in in the end um so
what we did was try to we had to end up
doing a future freeze but we um
restructured the team so that we were
still able to respond to our various
like business needs and so what we did
we had like one sort of engineering
manager like just dealing with like
inbound bugs and requests and making
sure that like nothing sort of fell
apart on the basically user facing
experience while everyone else um
basically transition the site Page by
page so um for example like how we
actually did this we would say uh like
de artist page um and what we would do
is build this page out exactly as it
exists it in our sort of Monolithic rail
stack but in the node stack ad tests um
have it up at some like our Roku app so
it would be like you know Arty node.
Roku app.com arid right and so people
can test it out we validate it um and
then we go in and actually add this
pretty cool little uh re it's not a
proxy but engine X and we um would have
basically an engine X redirector would
say all right all incoming requests to
art.net that start with SL
artistar um go to this new note out and
they would start serving traffic to it
and they would take only direct hits so
since our old app was a a backbone app
um it would sort of navigate and still
had our old um JavaScript running it um
and then after we validated the sort of
no app to take our production traffic
then we would go in and add redirects
from our like old backbone app to this
to the no app so would do a full page
reload it's a little bit tedious to go
to do this but it allowed us to
transition our our whole site Page by
Page in a way that was safe um and then
once we transition this and that was
safe in that like if the Noe app went
down we could just remove the AJ proxy
internet re and like we be F right they
be like oh yeah like site didn't
actually go down always had back um and
that would never happened like node
great and so but it was nice to have
that back up um and then
eventually after transitioning Page by
Page um we had a few pages that we
didn't want to transition um so we we
actually used node hdp proxy to proxy um
to the old app after after sort of
putting this new node app in front
of.net um that allowed us to like we
have some like admin functionality that
it's just like ha stuff that we don't
really we want to actually replace
rather than duplicate um and so it's
like productivity wise makes sense to
just use the not H proxy so actually as
a note it was we're still holding on to
this one feature that's waiting on
design that's like the one route which
is SL so we're redesigning our posting
Eli it's like so productive to know that
for the first time in our Liv we're
actually waiting on designers to build
features so that's basically the reason
for that yeah true it's good problem now
um and like we're not the Bott um so now
I need to talk a little bit about like
this node this mysterious not stack that
we use U so we use pretty standard tools
um backbone browser by Express um we
host on Heroku we use basically a miror
two uh Heroku servers uh
to large instances and all of our assets
are pushed to S3 and then fronted byr um
and then we do caching and redit um so
this is actually like an interesting
sort of exploration for us um we found
that um having a node app that basically
has to place a bunch of API requests to
our existing app before rendering a page
is you know it could be faster it's
basically u b prior API which has like
say 100 to 300 millisecond response time
and so if you place a bunch of
consecutive quests like you would up up
a really long pa um that's that so we
looked at like a lot of different
solutions for caching um the sort of
West caching strategy you can do is is
just putting the whole site put a
putting a CDN in front of the whole site
right so like every time you hit a route
we add like cach headers and it get to
put in Cloud front and like you're
you're not even hitting our servers
you're just Cloud front for this sort of
say artist ID to any world uh we found
that to be very problematic and that um
say whenever we deploy new assets the
asset path changes uh you the CDN expire
say maximum or the fastest it could
expire is something like every 12 hours
so you have people like getting 12h hour
hold assets for a while we had a bug
that we had mistakenly push to
production like we couldn't get rid of
it for
that would be really de um and so we
pretty much mixed that and U then looked
at sort of whole page caching so the
idea is that we would we would use Redd
um but whenever we rendered the the sort
of artist page we would render the whole
thing and then stick it in Redd um and
then the next time someone wanted to
riew that page they would just check you
know get the version out red we found
that to be kind of difficult because we
have different content for log in and
log out users and then we have like
different roles and like we could solve
it definitely a problem we could do but
seems like a lot of work um and so we
ended up settling on this kind of funny
little thing which was just overriding
back when scene um so that it would
always if you pass any sort of parameter
like in our case just cash true it would
check redis um if it's not there go to
the API and then put it in redis and
then use the a use the full URL with all
the qurs as the reddest key and then the
Json that our API responded with as the
content and then our API has sort of a
we use like a standard 12h hour
expiration for that and it it works
pretty well and it's that up our page
load time and now I think our average
node page load is around like you know
60 to 70 monds like those those Rus
calls are like around 10 mills and so
that's that's great that was like we're
like oh okay like problem solve like
that it's like 12 lines of code
it's called
um yeah back caption so yeah that's and
Craig is going to talk about which is
the framework that we use or B plate
that we used to build these new
applications so we um as for mentioned
we open source the cach library as well
as the server side backgound syn adapter
and this sort of led up to a lot of
different small open source projects
that culminated into diesel boiler plate
um so what is diesel uh basically it's
the boiler plate we use the bootstrap
new node projects uh specifically API
consuming client node projects it has
three uh points to its velocity which
are modularity flexibility and
isomorphic or R JavaScript on both the
server and client and share as much as
say
can
so as Des I in that a little bit how it
does modularity it breaks up your
project into Apps components and project
level libraries so apps are SL Express
applications mounted into your main
project um components are basically
modules of reusable UI that groups your
JavaScript CSS and related uh assets or
templates and tests so it keeps them
nicely self-contained which is a very
simple pattern that I've seen other I
research other node projects and it's
like something i' see common in node as
even my component JS project and uh is a
like node module that wraps this
philosophy up so it's thank you no
Community for promoting a big even
simple pattern
toop um and so I think probably right
now be a good time to dive into easel
I'll start to try to bootstrap show you
going from zero diesel project and what
it's like to see RC's main desktop
website and how big that is but before I
dive into that does anyone have any
questions about what's gone over so
far yeah I have a few
questions so you said that you change
your test testing from Happ
to
running how much
that
like night
day oh um sorry so the question was uh
after moving test to node off
integration selenium driven at thing how
much faster and how much lighter weight
was it and so that like night and day
we're talking hours of parallel machines
on CI like that only our CI could run
and our tests run like 1,500 tests run
under 5 minutes on your local machine
it's a lot of unit testing individual
modules it's a lot more lightweight and
it's all in node instead of having glue
together Ruby and sing in any other like
no things necessary to Bo up an entire
ra
Ser clarify really quick um so one thing
you do lose when going from a monolithic
project to like multiple separate
projects is the like competent that they
will actually all work together um and
so one of the things that we built is we
have another sort of purely testing
project that say checks out this an
easel based project checks out the
latest version of the API and then
actually runs test sort of integration
test weite of like those things together
right like in a in this environment
we're like stubbing the responses of the
API and so we're operating on
assumptions of how those responses work
and if they change it could break the
app and so this way we can like validate
um that process sure right now you talk
about like how you
handle interesting and not totally Sol
question maybe you'll get
a yeah I mean in general like our
deploys take like 5 minutes so if
something breaks and it changes we can
like mostly like respond with the fix
very very quickly
um question was which
using my question
is so it sounds like what you
built this is kind of similar not
exactly but in a way especially on
client side similar toor I'm wondering
meteor can communicate the same code
between client and
server so so that's an interesting point
um sorry I just wonder if you considered
that before you started this and so why
notuse it sure no that's a good question
um question was it sounds sort of like
meteor and then we consider other
projects that do things like meteor and
so that that definitely have so looked
at meteor looked at Derby looked at
render which is a very similar uh
concept and um meteor and Derby are very
full stack if you take control your
database and it's very hard to integrate
with our existing API and existing data
layer and it's also those are both very
real time heavy projects for our case we
weren't doing a lot of Real Time stuff
we simply needed to optimize a couple
pain points mainly being optimizing
initial page load um we didn't have to
be single page didn't need to be update
to the client project so we didn't need
to do a lot of the faner real time stuff
also we need why not render um which is
very similar us this back server client
ring server client at the time render
was uh still even sell prototype
although it sounds like at5 now and
Spike BR is a genius a very awesome dude
so like love rendered but also for our
case it was we wanted something bit more
modular renders kind of like render the
entire pay server build a sort of uh
framework that then passes off the
entire app with the client side of do
appication for our needs for instance we
might have a static Val cage that's just
a simple justs be all rendered on the
server or something else that's very
client side heavy we didn't want a
project that would prescribe something
to the way that rendered it although it
was also a very interesting project and
it doesn't more on the isomorphic end of
things like it shares routing whereas
this uh architecture doesn't try to tell
you how to share rout just gives you the
minimal layer that's necessary to be
able to run around the server and make
it easy for you to do
that um okay I think I'll take one more
before I that um did your switch to note
help you deal with the size of a single
page app and the problem with single
page app or did you retain the same back
data set and just change underlying Coda
um so node helped in the fact that we
can do more on the server and now have
to rely on everything being push the
client one of the bigger WIS is just the
heavy modular philosophy of being able
to break up your application into
smaller pieces that can use smaller
asset which I'll show you in second how
to do
that okay one
more um sorry so we're also on the fact
of uh migrating a monolitic application
to
uh sort of micro Services uh platform
and I was wondering how uh in the
process of proxying uh old routes and
old Pages uh if you had to deal with uh
synchronizing sessions and whe
synchronizing sessions between the
Legacy app and the new app and how you
dealt about that like how you de with
exper uh expiration and and refreshing
the sessions yeah so that was definitely
a big thing point and we'll definitely
cover that towards the end but I don't
know yeah I guess we do super quick um
so interestingly like there it's a
bigger problem than we had anticipated
and that we have an an HTTP and https
version which um don't share cookies in
some cases ra does a lot with it so you
can in theory be logged in sort of in
like four different ways right like the
HTP versus the htps version of the not
app and the HTP and htps version of the
real right that's bad um so we took this
opportunity to switch to HT https only
um and that simplified it a lot um but
in general we had um in both
applications U on the client we place
like an API request to say like just am
I check am I actually still
authenticated if not log me out and
redirect me to the same page that I'm on
sort of transparently so that's that's
one way and then whenever you log in
from the node app it would always also
log you into to the um existing
rail it would place it would sort of log
you in twice twice yeah and that was a
way that we synchronize it and if you
logged out from one it would log you out
from the other as well so we did have to
like change those behaviors and uh
synchronizing the sessions so let's say
you spend 20 minutes on the new section
which is not power the other the other
one is actually being expired is getting
expired right touching the session is
you might run into a chance that that
the other session expires while you're
still navigating this session as a
logged in user yeah I mean in the case
we just check we just place a request to
like the sort of you know I'm a user get
my data route and see if that Fails Like
and we do that on each new page Lo um
it's fail and then that was what we did
while we were doing the transition now
it's like deal um it was is an
interesting but
that off was definitely a b pain point
for us in synchronizing off especially
during transition okay so let's dive
into um actually easel itself and sort
of show you how this whole thing works
so I'll go ahead and uh pull up the
terminal
here so to get running on easel yourself
you would simply do
all okay so eel's a basically like it's
similar to express generator scaffold
project it's just a little command mine
tool that puts the project together for
you so npm install
diesel
bubly
so there we go now I have diesel
tool diesel version it's very
lightweight so anyways um and to get
boost drop project simply easel the
project
name goes ahead and creates that uh
directly for you it's a very lightweight
scaold so you just need to move into the
directory npn install get in the
dependencies this fair amount of
dependencies a lot of other modules that
P my in into something
else and so feel free to like one thing
about easel is that it's like you should
really break it apart and use whatever
you want it's very unrestricted so if
you don't like make files or for grun or
something or you don't like j prer a
different templating mustache then feel
free to do so um so now I have uh easel
project that's generated and to start uh
this example that uses GitHub API it's a
very simple example and I'll show you
how it works just run meas so that runs
the
server and we'll pull up a very basic UI
here that does just shows you the latest
commits from nrt repo and it's initially
renders this template on the server so
you disable JavaScript and it's
there you bring it oops Qui
um and if you enable JavaScript you can
now use it to
render the same template list template
on the client so this project is reusing
this list template on the server and
client to remember the same
view so pull here
uh so it shares the same background
models and templates on the server
client render so here's simple commit
module part model so if you're familiar
with backgr should look very familiar um
we'll go diving down into the commits
app to show you how it pulls that model
in on the um server so here we go
requiring the commits collection again
it's just a backround collection also
again look familiar we're using
browserify uh which is most of the magic
that does this browserify is a library
that lets you write your client side
code as a for node modules so giv your
require client and that lets us be able
to write modules that can be run
potentially serve our client as long as
we're using JavaScript that can run both
environments so in this case models is
just domain logic there no reason we
can't do this so here in our routes file
this is where we're it's like this is a
sub express application it's pulling in
a routes file this is just the index VI
so here's commit collection instantiate
it fetch it on success uh render that
view I won't get into the rest of it
just yet um on a client you do a similar
thing require the command is a
background view uh should also again
backbone should be pretty familiar um
and
we're going on this collection sync
render given this list template so this
is a browser apply transform and what's
cool about browser apply is you can
require not only Jas modules but with
transforms you can require things like
templates like Jade files with the jile
transform which is what we're using here
and that gives you a
function that you can use to create that
template so if you use templates on the
client side probably gives you a nice
interface to be able to require those
templates and use them on the client
pretty
transparently um so that shows you how
this very simple example works here and
you can with it being very flexible you
can basically utilize these things as
you see fit um I'll quickly show you how
this project is set up and how more of
the glue magic works so this is the our
setup file it's basically the like main
Express server and setting up all the
things that are necessary to start that
Express server so one of the bits of
magic is a little tiny Library we wrote
called sherifi and that's a very small
module that lets you share data between
the client and server so it can do
bootstrapping of data if you have for
instance in this case we want to pass on
the DAT just F from the server to the
client so we say res locals. SD short
hand for sherifi data. commits equals
the commits Json so it's passing on that
Json data to the client so we want to
refes it on the
client as well as any configuration so
here we have our API URL which is the
GitHub API being pass sherifi all that
stuff is available to you on from the
client by doing require
sherifi um that data here so you can see
how SD is this shorthand name space
we're using on the server and
client uh going further down like I said
before we wrote a server side backbone
sync adapter very straightforward uses
super AG use server side request for
backbone syn so you can use backbone def
on the server um gives you this little
helper to make sure that your GitHub
happy and passing our user agent um
here's this is just some mounting
sherifi some asset compilation
middleware that we wrote that's that
comes with stylist on a small
library for development purposes and
finally where we Mount all our set
Express
applications um okay and so to
testing I think this is a good
opportunity while this application is
quite small to show you how testing is a
lot nicer here so
in see okay so let's start with
something simple how do model test work
well it's nice again that we can write
our models in the way we write node
modules then we can just require it into
mocha directly so model test is pretty
straightforward require my model test
one mocha on it insert some things great
that test my client side and server side
model um to get a little little bit more
complex here's a view
test
and this uses a library we wrote called
Bend short for browser environment which
is just a bunch of helpers for studing a
browser environment and node so you can
unit test R viws simply so in this case
we have Ben setup that's setting up JS
th into our node process then R render
is a helper to say here's a server side
template I have and you render it in my
Js thong so that this view is actually
based off what the server would have
endered
and passing in local whatnot and then
finally benefit disos is to you have
Global libraries not everything can be
commonjs wrapped so just Expos the
helper that say we expected J to be
globally available you know J
J um okay so that's a simple diesel
project uh diving really into nuts and
bolts of that oh and finally integration
testing this is pretty straightforward
you ever use head headless integration
like zombie fire zombie we have an
integration helper that runs our app on
a p 5000 so that we can
easily visit with zombie our app and
actually assert things so we have two an
extent full stack testing here just we
have to St the
API okay uh so I'll try to run faster
through our large actually production
application here
this so this is our actually source code
for our production desktop
application
and to dive through the similar
architecture here we're going we use
copy scripts so I apologize anybody is
not famar with copy script or has any
hatred towards it I
understand and we rning use emac so we
don't have syntax highlight in
here um but hopefully we can still make
sense out of this
uh
so okay yeah so again here's that that
sharify bit but obviously a lot bigger
cuz we have a crack ton of configuration
that we're passing
um here's moving for further down we
have
backbone uh sink overwriting here and
here's where we're using our background
cach sync library to augment our server
side backgound sync to use R for caching
on the
server development middleware for asset
compilation some more project app level
Express level middleware that we use
specific to RC's
application and as as you can see here
is where we really break up our
application into lots of tiny little
apps where we are requiring into our
apps folder and mounting all sorts of
small
applications um so to dive into that sub
application architecture here's our as
folder and apps can be big or small
again flexibility being a philosophy of
this
project uh it can be as simple as our
page app which is literally like our
terms and conditions
page this is rendered entirely on the
server doesn't even use backr on the
client um there's our whitelisting this
URLs our routes file basically get the
page fetch it fetch it cash it and
render the template and there's no
client side uh JavaScript at all or it
can be really
complex like our Fair app which which
kind of looks a bit like a easel project
of its own has components folder of its
own this thing is
like this really
intense half Ser like half server to
half Client app where we have this a lot
of this stuff if we disable JavaScript
here you'll see that a lot of it's
rendered on the server but then a lot of
it is also rendered on the client and
it's just like this massive massive
thing browse portion of that now so
here's what you get on the server and
then spinner CU a client and then
disable JavaScript and a whole bunch of
other stuff starts rendering on the
client and this is all sharing the same
models sometimes the same
templates kind of goes
on with this whole crazy background F
side power event driven filtering UI and
so in here we have organization that's
more appropriate for that we have sub
components one for the browsing
filtering UI we have boots scrolling
layouts we have tons of routes here we
even have a library that does a fair
specific caching bit because there's
just so many API routes to pull into
this thing so we want to have a middle
Weare that compiles that together makes
it easy to pass on to the W routing so
that's just an example of how you can
build apps in very different ways and
it's really up to you to decide what
organization makes sense for app
um so I think last I'll dive the
components to show you sort of an
example of how this works so really it's
very straightforward um as you can see
here this this is these are all sort of
UI things we have something like flash
or a junp component and they can also
range in complexity so the jump
component is for
example oh yeah I guess it was right
there um on pages where you have a long
scrolling thing the jump component is
just this little arrow in the bottom
right and it's used throughout the app
so we want to make it easy to pull this
in wherever we need to across apps
across pages and it's a client s client
side thing so being able all this uh
these tools these isomorphic tools and
this this uh architecture makes it
really simple to say require this jump
View and pull in the styles from that
jump component and now my page has it
and I'll show you in a second what that
means about making smaller assets
tailored to each page that ended up
reducing our JavaScript and giv us
package files for the size and again
ranging complexity so as you had seen
before this filter UI which is now this
is the Armory show like but inside the
fair we use this really intense complex
filtering UI we also use a version of it
on the browse page that's its own sort
of more strip down filtering UI but they
share a lot of same functionality and
rendering so how do we St we share this
well we extracted it into a project wide
component that we can require in the
individual pieces of that component
necessary to build out the UI for each
page this just makes it a lot saner and
a lot more modular to be able to say I I
need these bits of UI pull them into G
specify that these things are going to
make up my asset package and now I have
asset package that's only fling in what
it needs and it's really easy to reuse
these different
parts
um
so finally how does that asset pipeline
work uh it's very straightforward again
with having stylus and browser prod giv
your requires it makes it pretty easy to
just have this assets directory that
describes each of the asset packages we
want and as you can kind of see here
each page has its own asset package and
for instance on the tag page we pull in
all the tags client side code for the
JavaScript package and for the stylus
stylesheet package we can pull in each
individual component necessary to build
up that UI and finally the the app
itself all those file sheets from an app
and to specify that that was our package
we just simply use a little Jade local
here that says my asset package is tag
on used that those assets and that means
that package doesn't pull in the
components it doesn't use it doesn't
pull in the other apps JavaScript or css
it doesn't use it just pulls in stuff
tail to which means we can optimize page
load very nicely and that's just like a
bonus of the mod
architecture and finally for there's
like very simple nicity of having this
isomorphic stuff uh we use npm for our
client side and server side dependencies
and again are isomorphic modules on npm
like MJS the paring Library we just
require on client or server no problem
so it's a nice win that we don't have to
even think about adopting a client side
pach dependance dependency manager we
have it builtin with npm and anything
that isn't on npm we can point the
GitHub and pull in that
way so that was easel CH I know like
very big
not uh so if you're interested in diving
even more go to eel js. it's
e you can go dos and
Bo okay uh so I hope I have not made
everyone to go to sleep through that and
we're going to wrap up with some pain
points and wins or
Ming
all right so we talked a little bit
about pain points um someone now mov
asked about saking off um that was
certainly certainly an issue but
basically making each App log in and log
out from both apps um was was our
solution there and moving to the hdps
only simp
that um another problem that we're we're
still investigating um is uh memory
usage and leaks so um our app it's
memory leaks and node is is tough um and
it's it's a very hard problem um we
currently believe there is a a um memory
week in New Relic um so we've disabled
New Relic and our looking at other uh
Monitoring Solutions so I would advise
like monitoring your memory usage when
you add to very very closely ours um
grows overnight to be in the like
multiple gigabytes per machine uh which
is a lot uh but starts but then every
restart goes back down to around 1 or
200 megab so it's it's kind of a dramat
like a very odd uh me and um
uninstalling neur has pretty much fix it
for
us
so yeah beware um npm G stability it's
like not that big of a problem lately
like uh we haven't noticed it going down
um but to fix it um and to basically
like even npmjs recommends this now um
but if you have a Deployable app you
should check in your node module um it
gets kind of weird in GitHub when you
submit a pro request and you add a new
node module and it's like 20,000 lines
of change and you just like added a node
module and you're like uh but it does
allow you to always be able to P your
app and like at the end of the day like
that is code that your app is using and
it's useful to be able to like to know
when that has changed and if it has cost
F so I would recommend uh recommend
doing that um there's some really good
blog posts about why to check in your
node modules um but we I guess we'll use
this platform to request a GitHub ignore
file uh where like when you submit a for
request it would ignore the node modules
changes in the viewer so that you could
then like sanely review foress um we
kind of have like decided to try and
submit the proquest with changes get it
sort of through so it's like this is a
great change and then update the forest
with the new change later in the um it's
all um and we also talked about um like
integration testing um which is where we
have a sort of thirt project from our
API and our client app that checks out
both and tests the integration between
them um because at the end of the day
when you're building a sort of node
Style app that's an API consuming app
like you're stubing the API in all tests
and you need to make sure those
assumptions remain
true um and Craig is going to quickly
talk about some of our WIS so hopefully
a lot of this become sort of obvious
over this but uh commun use amazing modu
ecosystem allows this isomorphic thing
to happen where introducing this idea to
RT was very much everyone was very
skeptical but it's actually with enough
Comm support it was quite easy to put
together um npm server and client
amazing package manager that we need to
just use server client um we didn't need
to really make any contributions before
it's nice uh
productivity has been light years better
testing with it's a lot faster um it's
actually more like, 1500 tests now under
5 minutes our deploys are a lot
faster 20 to5 minutes and we used to
have to like deploy once a week because
this took so long for CI to get ready
and now a smaller project faster test
just everything across the board
productivity is better performance which
is not necessarily Focus except for page
load speed is great uh so we cut our
page load speed in half we went from 40
plus gr servers that we had to scale in
uh High track times and we're just we've
been hming along the whole time on a bug
three on for node servers so we have two
node servers running production desktop
website um and mobile website and we can
optimize SEO as well being a runer and
server even though we use other methods
uh optimize that as well besides not but
anyways that's all I got so thank
you so what do you use to measure uh
Fage load uh speeds and
Benchmark we did use New
Relic Relic U but actually if you go to
dashboard DN onu uh dasoku app
or whatever and um it'll they have a
nice um like response time graph memory
usage
graph uh typically the measurement you
get to see is the the U uh request SL
response time whereas F Lo is basically
uh not just that it's also the essence
right so we so with New Relic they have
they call it uh rum or like real user
monitoring and so they integrate with
your note application and whenever you
render a page they include the sort of
like start time
at the top and so you get the full
request CLE that way aw um it's pretty
cool um memory leaks for to uh check it
out because we have the new Rel uh yeah
it's a relatively um New Relic node is
being like very very actively developed
um and so they they've added like tons
and tons of new stuff um they now do
like refres qway U which is nice we
there this is ASN web server so there
really shouldn't be very much of that um
um but
they and uh another question so
regarding your gas uh uh in
infrastructure uh Heroku is not
something you can host in house so what
do you do for local development uh and
staging for example do you always just
push everything uh remotely and you
which requires an internet connection or
do you have an alternative local
alternative yeah we just we use use
GitHub to Hoster source code and we pull
that into a local development
environment and then push that use pull
request ciew and use another BR server
to do the staging environment and we
just we have a Jin CI machine that we
use for one click deploy and we use
Travis for C GitHub it integrates really
easily but yeah staging and Environ are
just remote Serv we used to have
personal Deb remote uh systems but for
this project we didn't really so it's
all
local thank you know
many know it's the like 2x I know onu um
I think it's a pretty wi um yeah there's
like a gig of memory and I don't know
how
many you uh you showed the uh the jump
component but I was curious with with
some of your other components how is
composability on it can you just sort of
mix and match do you have a lot of
design flexibility or yeah I mean I'll
show you for instance in the
filter uh that's one of our more
complex
pieces
okay
so this filter component again it's very
flexible feel free to break it down in
the smaller component so this component
itself is actually broken down into the
nav uh view which
is
uh this this one deals with
specifically the overall sort of
highlighting and serializing of rams
that are used in this
navigation so it doesn't deal with
individual pieces but it will update
your URL and update how can math
and there's other pieces of that so
there's
like the router that deals with the
actual routing of the BRS is this one
actually just simply deals with the
counts on the left and finally this one
gets pulled into a larger component it's
like pulling all of those sub components
into this thing that I can just drop in
into certain views so this one itself is
then required into an app like browse
page well let's do something simpler
actually like the tag page you have this
is used on tag filtering as well
uh so here we go even simpler filter
widget and here we would pull it in as a
backround view that's required out the
components that gets used inside of the
tag View and attached and you have some
Brands to update some pretty like
typical background architecture stuff
and how that works for its
styling is
we
have used stylus to easily import and
pull together style sheets so this pulls
in the individual components to build a
bigger uh component level Styles sheet
and then that Styles sheet is pulled
into the app level um style sheet right
here and so that way the that page
itself knows okay I need all the styles
from Filter component filter component
like pulling all the styles from my sub
components and that makes it so it's
really like nothing fancy or magical
it's just using your requires and folder
directories to isolate parts of your
half uh also we leave tests inside of
the components themselves so that things
are nice and selfcontained and need to
experiment Anda things you just be like
we're not using this component anymore
the we five and remove
where how do you handle name spacing
within like the CSS oh yes that's that
was a good plan glad you asked that
because the we adopted a simple pattern
that um there's a blog post by Phil
Walton and that's amazing and he talks
about CSS architecture but we adopted
just a very simple thing you name space
your styles by component name or app
name and that's gone far enough for us
to keep our um styles away from other so
like in the filter component we'll have
things like filter Dash sore count pull
down or filter Dash so everything needs
to be name spaced sort of by the folder
directory and that way things are nice
and separated not each other so I
noticed an earlier screen of CSS that
sort of nested and I'm wondering are you
moving from that pattern to this pattern
or are you using well we yeah so the
nice thing about name space thing is you
really you don't have to nest and makes
your again all leads to like smaller
asset sizes because you don't have the
pre-processor is building out these huge
duplicated Styles you just have warm
decoration so for the most part this
lets you keep things very
unnecessary how do you guys uh deal with
debugging when you're requiring inside
of
require uh do you mean like circular
requires no how do you know it's uh the
file that's do the required or the
actual source file that's broken uh so
it's all I'll show you test I mean it's
basically like it's all very much P per
low up a modle basis I mean we we test
each individual component you're
requireing the view JavaScript and use
again to help set that up is that your
question I just saw a couple modules
that we're requiring there another
module so oh yes how do we I I got you
yeah how do we stub like a module that
depends on many other modules so that we
we St a lot of the external so um like
we wrote for it's not like comes with
easel we WR a little test helper that's
like St my child classes in case one
view depends on a lot of many smaller
views sometimes it actually just works
we don't have to St the sub classes but
often times you don't want to get into
this hairy thing where you're like here
is this larger level view that well it's
more like here's this app level view
that's using all these smaller
components you test the component unit
test components unit test the app level
logic stubbing out the components and
then we rely on zombie for integration
testing the mix of them all because you
can really go down alol if you try to
like accompany every single dependency
that get pulled into
your um the first slide you had to stack
which is ined aoku Rd now is this just
for your read only at or is this fully
Redd or
so oh yeah okay so we're not using redus
to store any sensitive data at all if
our Rus instance like dive this side
would be totally fine um it's really
just to cash requests from this node app
to our API um and just to make that jump
faster um our API is about like to 300
milliseconds and this is like 10
milliseconds and so it just speeds up
that and then brus allows you to do sort
of like multi- gets or multi sets and so
you could say instead of fetching like
five a request either sometimes you have
they have to be fetched synchronously uh
we would just like sort of fetch them
all synchronously once and then set them
all in red us under one sort of big key
I guess um and Craig showed that in the
fa application um um when he's mentioned
using some cing nowhere
here
wew um so this is
effectively um yeah um it's it's getting
a ton of keys at the same time from the
cab um and
then it's a lot of and that's a lot of
different API requests that we would
have had to fetch in parallel ornly um
so this makes the page much
much it's like
a we we use R for other backend projects
but they not necessarily
projects one thing that you
guys
or oh um we've I think we're using like
redest green now I don't I don't
remember redest to go there's there's
like a ton of them um I think we just
found the like size that we needed and
like the plan that's the cheapest
amongst all of
them addon yeah a Rog addon um it was
really easy to set
up yeah any other questions aen are
there any like um you're
doings St sheets
whatever
so asked
us do a really good job at this and uh
this is already such a like new
environment for Deb team work that I
want to introduce some of the boiler
plates
TOS encourages which is writing P like
Jon piles for basically every section of
du wanted to build it would be a matter
of like right js on CLE these things
where we got buy just like the required
informance that come with it a little
bit of here's how you should structure
your stuff component sort of takes this
idea and it and they do a good
job and they have amazing modules like
you can reuse component models with npm
and requir as
well so uh in your diagram uh you show
that uh you've broken the monolitic into
a more of a front end
server uh note powered front end server
as well as um a ruby API is it just one
API or multiple apis um yeah right now
it's just 1 API and it's just version
one of that one API um we are going to
be expanding and working on an API V2
and then other apis potentially from
other apps um but what we do to manage
that it wouldn't be a big change for us
like so if you look at any of the even
like
I okay so like here we have like a URL
declaration and we use this API URL
variable which we which we' imported
from Chile right and that's declared in
the apps configuration so we could in
theory have like you know other API URL
um and then use that as the URL for this
background
collection and so use Jason um sorry
rest rest to communicate leave right is
that the messaging
know yeah we have a a fairly restful
full Ruby API and it plugs in the
background really nicely and like brenon
said we just have actually should click
on it it has some
sensitive but giant
it but if you saw that for corner it's
basically a giant Json thing and we can
use sherifi to say only these Keys get
pulled up to the client and those key
are fired on
certain so you mention that it took guys
months to get your mobile so what the
time oh it's it also took four months we
we're already over we're all all down
all traffic going say took four months
four Debs and mobile website which is
much smaller project is four months like
one and a half two
deaths what is your data
score where is your data
score yeah so for our data is pretty
much entirely like 99% in that Ru API
that's back by m mid for
the we have other SES as BR said decou
more we have other project project that
use
postr uh this project itself uses RIT
for caching some app have their own but
mostly so you
IM
so you
guys um we're all you're all pretty
adapted to the background Cent and I was
like the Pioneer on the Node front and
try to keep again like I want to adop to
things that I have to and another reason
I didn't want to go down meteor or other
routes I want to keep it back things
that pretty familiar with uh so for the
most part it wasn't too difficult to get
people to know like use background on
the server there is a more of a learning
curve when you have to be like that's
what you do on the client side but this
is a persistent server State you can't
do that kind of thing or like here's how
you should be doing a s in the server
versus on client but for the most part
the server side isn't doing insanely
different Stu and like fetch some data
from some background models and pass it
into a template so it was fairly
painless to on board people I'd say the
most difficult part is it wasn't
necessarily like building out new
features but was the testing tool and
how sort of different they are and being
able to like sely debug and sort of stub
your failing test um you may
particularly in like internet driven act
you often times need to sort of you like
your view that you're testing may may
like trigger an event you need to sort
of stub that and then like execute that
event and then make sure that it calls
the calls the function using the result
and doing that in a testing environment
is very different from what we were
doing before which was like a full
integration test where you're running
into in a browser and it was just going
to kind of do that like here you have to
um force it um which it's interesting uh
and it it's like we've got better about
it um but I think that's would be a
great um an area for like future
Improvement in node is like better
testing
tools yeah it you know it's like take
the client and put this no process and
you when you do an integration test
you're like fire browser and drop my
state like entirely whereas here we're
unit testing use or state persists
between tests you have to be more
careful about doing things globally or
um noticing knowing how to like debug a
browser environment headlessly is
definitely one of the bigger pain points
of
that yeah I mean overall I'd say that
like the biggest wins like again we are
a startup and we're trying to basically
be able to build like the best product
we can that's like as sort of as
reliable as possible but mostly we're
trying to be productive like we need to
be able to build these features in a
very competitive environment and and you
be able to build them like well and fast
and
components uh structure has allowed us
to be just incredibly productive um and
that we're just reusing previous uh
parts of the site and so a lot of times
when we're building a new feature it's
like oh like this other our sort of core
team manages the API it's like they add
the API point we figure out which
components we need we like assemble them
together use the new API and we're done
in like half a day it's like very very
cor um and that's really been the
biggest win for us uh from this
architecture and it's reliable it's fast
it's easy to deploy and test and very
fast it does um that's
awesome and so you're generating enough
on the server side to satisfy witho
needs and then it's just pting on its
own sort of um so that's a whole thing
I'd say uh we could uh but basically um
we have a variety of different um
experiences that we give to people um
for us the primary thing is making our
users have a great experience and so we
built this mainly to
say B say like render give up the fold
content on the server give the person
that sort of like initial page
incredibly quickly then as the sort of
Client app loads in assemble the rest of
the components of the site like they
have something already and so it's it's
a great experience there um for SEO what
we do is we actually have uh for only
for pages that require client side
rendering at all um we have another
service and that CWS our site uh
periodically and then stores all of like
the HTML for a PR rendered page on S3
and then we use um the sort of Escape
fragment uh meta tag so if you look at
um I think like any page on RT so I can
go to this page and I can say question
markor underscore equals very H and then
this so I'm now getting what Google Sees
so as you can see um the cropping the
you know it doesn't fill the width of
the page as well it's not going to load
in any extra stuff cuz there's no
JavaScript um but effectively this is
entirely pre-rendered page and so how
you do this is uh Google has some good
docs on it
um um but basically you have this meta
name BR total gibberish basically um but
that's what that's that's Google um so
yeah you add that to your page and then
Google will crawl it with this meta tag
and and with our sort of
existing um engine X routing that we
talked about earlier we basically scan
for this peram and if it has that FR we
direct to
the certainly you could uh go to go to
distance and render everything on the
server wanted to but since we were
already building this thing out in par
at the time wasn't really use case to
solve although this is something that I
uh feel that render is good at getting
your convention for rendering an entire
page full a server and full page
from response to that you know people
Javas now why that is a good question
we're playing with all the voodoo of
Google's Magic yeah I mean we haven't
seen it yet on our site um so it's like
it's a very um it's an experimental
thing so for example there's like levels
here so it may execute JavaScript but it
may not Place exter external HTP
requests which it would have to do in
our case so like I would imagine if I
was building a crawler that would be a
very difficult thing right like
executing JavaScript is one thing but
like crawling the entire internet and
then letting then placing all the entire
internets like external HTP requests
that they place like say for all their
ads for all their like other stuff like
that's a lot of burden on a web crawler
and I would imagine that's not something
that's actually going to come soon from
Google
um and so since our app depends so much
on placing external hdp requests to
render um we bu this may think it's a
good like longer term thing that's
reliable uh is that it it's
good okay thank you very
much